we like to go to tiktok to the lost  souls of tick tock  and uh kind of give them some advice so  let's uh let's go to the first one in  order to avoid the friend zone you have  to be aware of the things that get you  friend zoned and not do those things  like asking her how her day was if you  are wasting your time texting a girl  throughout the day to a point of where  you can have a conversation of how our  day is going you're doing something  wrong if you got a man  who's on social media giving all kinds  of advice about how to be a man  i want to know his resume like what do  you know about being a man  have you ever even made meat at a  barbecue are you married do you have  kids like i need to know all these  things before i'm to take advice from  you about how to be a man  if you're with a woman  who will be turned off  because you ask her how her day was  then that's just a good indication to  leave and go find  another woman just break up  take my voice